We're now going to teach my daughter here about some of these software components within
a system because she's fascinated by that, aren't you, aren't you, Eliana? Truly. Okay, software components.
First, let's talk about firmware. What is firmware? Within a computer system, you have lots of hardware components. Some of the pieces that we've talked about, you have things like the hard drive, you have a motherboard, Southbridge, Northbridge, network cards, graphics cards, you have all these different hardware.
Firmware is this tiny little bit of software that runs on the hardware. I'll give you a perfect example of this. When you first turn on computer system and it's say a window system, you don't get the windows logo right away. What you get instead is usually a bunch of black and white text or maybe the manufacturer's logo. This is what is known as the BIOS, the basic input output system. This is some of the firmware that is getting your system booted up up and running when you first power it on. And so that's firmware.
Next, let's talk about the system kernel. And I want you to listen very carefully here. You are not going to confuse the system kernel with the security kernel. The security kernel is the implementation of the reference monitor concept.
The system kernel, which we're going to talk about now, is the core, the heart of an operating system. It does all the low level control, all the needy-gritty details of what it takes to run an operating system.
And it has access to essentially everything. And so protection, making sure that this system kernel is running correctly is extremely important.
And that's why we're going to talk about privilege levels. Because within a system, you can have different levels of privilege, higher privilege and lower privilege.
Higher privilege is going to give you access to more functionality, more ability to do things. And lower privilege, less so.
This next slide here shows kind of a generic view of what an operating system looks like. And the takeaway here, do not memorize any of the data in the boxes, any of the names of parts here.
But I want to show you one important part. And that is within a system, you've got the underlying hardware, you've got the system kernel, the operating system that runs on top of that. And then you'll have your applications.
What is going to be the higher privilege level here from a software perspective, the system kernel. And so the higher privilege level is called the system kernel. And the lower privilege level is called user mode.
So remember this on a computer system, the lower privilege level is user mode, and the higher privilege level is system mode or kernel mode.
Next, let's talk about this concept of middleware. 20 events is a lie. It's okay. Let's talk about middleware.
So middleware is essentially a person in the middle. So think of it this way, okay.
Your bank, you can use online banking with your bank, you can use a mobile app, you can go to a website, and you can do online banking.
But what do you think your bank's core banking system is based on? It's probably a mainframe system. It's very common in banks nowadays, even to this day, where their core banking system is still a mainframe system, a system that was designed and put in place 20, 30, 40 years ago.
Now, a mainframe system that was put in place 30 years ago, were they thinking about mobile applications and web-based applications back then? Absolutely not.
And so, thank you. When you have something like an application, a mobile app, talking to a mainframe, do those two systems speak the same language? They truly do not.
And so what we need in between them is a translator that can translate API calls from a mobile application into four-tran or cobalt commands on a mainframe system.
And so think of middleware as almost like a man in the middle, a translator between two different pieces of software that don't speak the same language.
And the security advantage of doing this is that because this middleware is all the communication is going through this middleware, it allows it to make decisions as to what requests can go in what direction, what data can be passed in different directions.
So that's the idea of middleware. You're fascinated by this, aren't you? All right, there you go. Those are some of the software components that you need to know about.
Thank you.